I'm actually for the last two years I
kept my Mac on Boston time because I'd
lived in Boston for 25 years
neither than the Bay Area so I keep it
on bay time bay time California time
okay hello everyone
this is a I'm going to be kind of
leaning to the right here because you're
more numerous okay but doesn't mean I
don't love you folks too
okay so here's the talk right here
hopefully this is what you think
oh dear that was kind of scary
okay party planning that sounds good
okay boom all right so here's the talk
so you'll get a couple of insights it's
this is a novice talk so I'm really
going to be trying to address how do you
even get started in these sorts of
things okay
and there's an abstract here and I think
there's some contact information
somewhere and it will help you around
today tomorrow on the next day so let's
make this small and we'll just start
here I was last time I was in New York I
was at Jupiter con and that was a lot of
fun and I did a poster so reuse
everywhere right so I kind of like munch
to poster some rather than doing some a
slide pack which is are like a run
through the poster quickly and then
we're going to actually do some live to
printer code just pizza toys always fun
to see what happens okay so the whole
idea of real estate is that it's
expensive it's hard to get and there's a
lot of money to be made and knowing more
about it alright so I'm not going to
read these to you if you were here in
July you could have read it for yourself
all right but
sorts of things that make this
interesting it's like here's Zillow
giving away 1.2 million to come up with
a better pricing model Redfin is in
there trying to figure out how to
disintermediate the realtor of basically
doing a short shading of commissions one
way or the other
they've gone public you can check their
price on your own okay so this talk is
about looking at a different slice of
the data I will take a look at the
Zillow slice very very briefly in just a
moment we're going to be looking at the
notion of a farm a realtor farm looking
up the realtor as being a key ingredient
in the pricing structure as well alright
so in order to determine what a farm is
to know what your area of geography is
important you know knowing your
longitudes and latitudes is really
important right with us so you know
whether our things are close enough to
constitute a cluster if that's what I'm
calling a farm yeah so there's a little
geography lesson here she countries
small countries and glaciers right those
are the numbers there and the tools
exist within Python yay and there are
some of the tools so what we'll do is
we'll set a threshold we'll look around
we'll try to see things that might kind
of go together right the notion of
clustering what goes together in terms
of real realtor transactions both on the
listing side and on the selling side the
selling agent is what the realtor who's
associated with the buyer is called
that's a little backwards in terminology
but it makes sense from within the
industry and we're going to use this
viciente mathematics have a picture of
this later on
and we're gonna merge these kind of
baskets together we're going to sort of
have putative points that seem to be
close enough to be interesting and then
we're going to see how much overlap
there is between those points and munch
them all together okay and let's see
we'll take advantage there we go
so those are the modules well that's
kind of interesting how this works
though sideways or forwards here we go
all right so we're going to be drawing
dots on a map which is always very cool
to do Google is going to help with that
you're going to look like this we're
going to draw circles and we're going to
figure out a convex hull and we'll sort
of look at whether or not the effect of
having whether certain Realtors have an
effect on the selling price relative to
the listing price now there are actually
several negotiations that take place
during a real estate transaction first
of all it could just be a for sale by
owner and a direct buyer no realtor
involved okay but that's fairly rare
just because of the logistics of doing
open houses qualifying buyers and
working through all the paperwork so
more typical is a situation where there
is a seller of the home who has a
missing agent who reports to a broker in
terms of fiduciary responsibilities on
the buyers side there is the selling
agent which also has a broker when the
house gets listed the listing price is
negotiated between the listing agent and
the seller of the home as are other
terms such as the length of the contract
and whatever other services the rotor
might provide
so that's the first negotiation the
second negotiation
happen between the buyers and the
selling right you actually come up with
the price relative to so one of the
things that I think is quite interesting
is how does the selling price relate to
the listing price and how does the
listing price relate to the appraised
price now the appraised price if you're
looking off of tax basis you know the
assessed value the boy that's all over
the place all over the country it gets
updated at weird intervals there's also
the mortgage the lenders appraisal right
that comes in a veil do it on the spot
if it's a cash buyer there's a mortgage
a waiver of mortgage contingency okay so
this is my my better half my realtor at
Hawk Zelda and she gave me some sort of
ideas about this whole thing
she used to be a data warehouse
Engagement Manager for
PricewaterhouseCoopers she got tired of
working with fake houses and now she
deals with real houses in Boston and in
California but sadly not New York all
right so this is a very cool chart that
uses graphics and I wish my charts where
it's cool as this this is paper scape
those of you who use archive X check out
paper scape yeah and if I could make my
charts look this cool I'd be very happy
all right so let's look at what Zillow
is doing all right so the typical real
estate commission is say between five
and seven percent for residential ten
percent for commercial my Commission is
split between this thing and selling
side buy some agreement and between the
agent and the broker also by some
agreement of both sides so they're
multiple splits going on
so people have different incentives in
terms of who they who they may sell the
house to you know if you have multiple
offers coming in right one
consideration is whether or not the
agent is going to take the recommend the
offer with the best Commission right as
opposed to the best return for thee
so that's covered by ethics and all
sorts of legislation no different than
any other fiduciary responsibilities
like an attorney or a stockbroker so if
we look at a property here in New York
New York oh that's cool
right 10% of that would be a hundred
thousand five percent would be about
fifty thousand right so there's serious
change involved in the Commission and if
we look at Zillow DH what are the rules
here valuation somewhere here here we go
they improved from fourteen percent
margin era to five percent now bear in
mind you could have two equivalent
offers there differ by five percent
roughly equivalent okay one offer has a
mortgage contingency and it has a sale
of previous home contingency and it has
an inspection contingency that's the
offer that's five percent higher the one
that's five percent lower than that
offer is not going to have any
contingencies if the owner wants to sell
quickly they're going to go with the
cash offer right without inspection or
contingency these are things that are
negotiated so when a realtor helps a bar
put together an offer right this might
be a consideration put it if you can get
the cash make a cash offer once you get
accepted you want to refinance that you
go right ahead but you're committed you
have to have proof of funds etc etc all
right so the thing about the Zillow
prizes there's little rules and I'm not
there's just going to have to trust me
on this I don't take the time to find it
they have a couple rounds on the data
and
the second round of data said though
that you can use any kind of dev you
want except for the kind of data
external data I mean except for the kind
of data that is typically contained in
an MLS Multiple Listing Service
information which is kind of begging the
question anyway I mean sickly there's a
lot of overlap there's square feet
number of bathrooms how old is the roof
what the taxes are so part of the reason
they may be wanting to avoid doing in my
lessons because MLS data is owned just
like Zillow data is owned and the major
source of income for Zillow right now
are realtors who are paying zero for
marketing to generate leads Zillow makes
very little money any other way so
having that relationship with the
Realtors is a love-hate relationship
right because the Realtors are paying
Zillow to do the generation and if they
don't get any leads it's not a good good
deal for them all right
so let's just look at what we're going
to be generating we're going to be
generating something like this and it's
too big too much let's go smaller so
this is California it's near the ocean
okay there we go and this is where I
relocated a couple years ago right over
to here one of these thoughts represents
the house I have okay so these are
transactions Berkeley not all the
transactions but I pulled some key areas
Albany Berkeley area San Leandro Fremont
right the Tri Valley over here Livermore
labs alright okay so let me very quickly
show you what the cago data looks like
but I didn't use any of the capital
Zillow data and what I'm going to show
you a couple minutes I did download the
data just to sort of see how it's
organized I think it's too late to enter
the competition I think they're already
on their second round and I'm using an
IDE Python notebook which I think there
would be several other talks on Jupiter
or ipython as it used to be called
that's how we do to launch it let me
make this feel larger in case you didn't
see that
like just Jupiter notebook and then the
name of the notebook and it's like this
big okay and I'm just going to go ahead
and Reese start and share all the output
because I think he's exciting to see
things happen is yeah so you can see
there's very little in this this
somewhat demonstrates how you use pandas
how you use the notebook okay
Fiore Novus you're a step ahead so there
is some training data and so it looks
like pandas very nicely organizes that
with headings for you gives you just the
front slice a tail slice if you see
there's a lot of activity in here this
Asterix means it's thinking so what
they're wanting you to do spoke with
estimates for prices depending on which
quarter house actually one on the market
to predict prices right in the future so
you didn't have prices that were already
they weren't asked either to create the
past they're asking you to create the
future and there are like two million
properties you know in this record
property database
okay so we're going to look for all the
properties that have more than twelve
bathrooms so this is some really
remarkable magic that you can just sort
of pop it in here
and number of bathrooms and oh yeah it's
cranking through two million properties
and I don't know I shouldn't take that
long
all right we'll let that cook for
whatever reason it's taking a little bit
oh there it goes I was still thinking
all right we'll just think over here and
I'm just going to come up with oh there
we go it wasn't too bad compared to the
punch card era where two hours or days
to get step back two or three minutes is
not bad
all right so you can see here is all
their information they're nicely
calculated okay
and more and more
all right so right here in their list
there were a fair number of properties
that's the part that had more than 190
properties I was at 2 million had more
than 12 bathrooms might be a motel
you never know it's a property right or
mansion and there's a really nice excel
those of you who still use Excel at work
or at home hand does have some nice
Excel information and boom boom okay so
this is the Zillow competition all right
no connection with Zillow think I'll
move that aside
actually I'm just gonna kill this window
the jupiter's sometimes I'm just gonna
shut down the Colonel's there so that
it's not taking up too much resource
okay so I'm going to have to note books
going and the first notebook is gonna be
my Python 2 version right I'm still kind
of mostly in Python 2 these days kind of
Python 2 Python 3 right according to the
latest stats ok all right
all right so let's spin that up any time
so eventually I'll post this code
somewhere but you can contact me if you
want it sooner
all right so in order to advance through
cells right there's the square brackets
tell youit's ie Python as opposed to
triple brackets for just bass Python and
the ipython notebook now Jupiter ju for
julia py for python R for R and I can
come up here to execute a so this one I
think runs so there we go and now it's
run all this code and so I'm going to be
using just a ragtag collection of things
GM plots probably the most interesting
thing on this list and all you shift
return to actually do the stepping
control faster and I'm just going to go
ahead and run through this there's a
couple versions of pickle depending on
which version of Python you're wrong the
convenience function oh I got spaghetti
code there right goes on for a while
right kind of works so there wasn't a
real need to break it up into lots of
functions because it's not a product yet
nice by probably well should alright
anyway we'll let that cook and I think
it's already done right it's just
definitions really there we go
all right so I'm going to go get the
data so I drew down all this MLS data at
one point and I massaged that I pickled
it too so pickling or json right it's
pretty much equivalent just used picol
in this case and we're going to grab and
this is what the young my last of the
data comes out so what I did I went
through and I found a geographic
longitude and latitude for every address
in the MLS listing right if I try to do
that real time I'm pinging the server
constantly and I would get some some
nasty messages for instance kind of
messages what I get
there we go
Oh things like this I would get timed
out too many requests no service all
those things that you don't want to have
happen during a live demo right so plus
you're going to be playing with the data
a lot once you have the longitude and
latitude there's no point in getting it
more than once so I was using a native
dictionary in order to sort of make each
address a key in my map file all right
so let's keep going a little more pandas
here we go so we have the listing agent
the listing date to list price the sales
right the selling agents square foot
etcetera and I needed to do some stuff
with dollar signs
whenever you work with real data it's
dirty it's never in the right format so
babble is a great place to work with
currencies one of several they have a
currency formatter then it should go
both ways if you have dollar signs and
commas to process it or to generate it
and we see right here right just another
look at this information okay so what I
wanted to do was to actually be able to
use a widget so I could just grab a
particular realtor the only problem is
the widget tool I found only works on
Python 3 it's I pi widgets really cool
stuff but yeah see it's not popping up
anything so what we're going to do is
we're going to pickle out some data come
over here and open up another notebook
and
let me get those recent one here
I can
[Music]
mm-hmm so now I have a Python 3 version
now it's possible to call like I could
have done this within my Jupiter
notebook directly but then that's just
more stuff to figure out
and I should really just convert this
whole thing to Python 3 at some point so
I'll just come up here and I thought
it'd be kind of interesting to see what
you're up against when you're trying to
use small clever ideas all right so one
of the things I discovered is and there
used to wit just you got to have this
super extension enabled first and we'll
see errors on that grips but then to
like about that
let's try that again
I have the wrong directory hmm let's
just keep going
all right so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to grab this here okay ah
okay Python 3 I'm juicing anaconda I
have a Python 3 environment I really
need support get moved over to Python 3
it's true anyway I'll just set this now
so presumably it won't bother us in the
future and let me get my notebook going
so these widgets are very nice to have
those of you who have any sort of
JavaScript in your blood you know all
about widgets okay so right here boom
there's one of my widgets and let me
just make this a little larger here and
I can just go ahead and scroll through
here and I'll pick one of the he just
gonna find one that actually was fairly
busy
[Music]
okay so rather than do that what I want
to do is I'm going to come down here I'm
actually going to find out which realtor
was busy they'll do the same thing here
I'm just going to ask for a rank so let
me look at the seventh busiest agent
troops
there we go hey it should still be okay
and let's see oh I need to set how big
my radius is I'm doing this in terms of
degrees because how it's not my
longitudes a lot our tutors set up okay
so I'll just go ahead and pump in a
value I'm just going to go with that
number there right and I'm going to find
out who so then the coke Ozzy is a very
busy realtor and a couple of sort of
trial by fire is kind of thing to figure
out how to actually pass things back and
forth turns out if you try using an
environmental variable it's going to not
work the environmental variable is only
local to the jupiter notebook
environment and it's children not to its
parents so in order to pass the values
across i did a hack by creating
temporary file so i will come over here
and you'll see all sort of grab that and
some things didn't work we'll skip that
didn't work because i couldn't change
this widget object that i had created
but i can get it right here it gives it
to us as a list and boom we'll just run
through this the interest of time
it's a waiting for know okay
Malthus and suffer through that I'm just
going to show you what some of the
results look like so right here these
are all the farms in the data set that I
work with this is these are the farms
for one particular realtor and if we
scroll over here here we go
all right so right here the size of the
circle indicates whether or not the
property sold for above or below the
list price have the circles here
indicate tentative farms now why do you
care if an a if a realtor knows the
neighborhood really really well does
that mean she's going to be able to sell
your house for more than a realtor who
doesn't are you going to give her the
listing because he's just a known face
so again you have to look at the listing
price negotiation as well because if you
have multiple cash offers or otherwise
truly equivalent offers you you may have
a bidding war more likely if you price
it below the final transaction price
rather than right at it right if you
price it above say the Zillow price
might not get any offers here's your
price it below you may get multiple
offers and end up going above the Zillow
price or at the other prices of that
sort okay
so there's me see if I can come back to
I'm a farm okay
what's it hanging on they probably got
time for questions I think we have two
minutes left
two minutes left okay so let's see if I
have example here from the previous room
so the situation is pretty when I looked
at kind of a couple dozen Realtors
clearly there are some realtors who
consistently under sold their listing
price and others that consistently over
so the listing price so this is just
areas to look right things like time of
year and of course the buyers urgency
and selling or factors as well so I
think it's a much harder problem than
Kaggle or that Zillow is saying and
talking to my wife whose experience has
been extensive on both coasts she'll see
offers that vary within 5% and things
like the closing date will be the the
main consideration so I don't know how
Zillow could ever estimate the price any
closer than that what people really want
when they're on the buying side is 5%
doesn't really matter to them as much as
can they qualify for the loan and can't
they get the property right so framing
framing the the offer so that's the
direction I'm heading in it's figuring
out how do we incorporate that kind of
knowledge so that a buyer or seller can
figure out what these other external
effects are in terms of you know things
like staging right and etc so I think
I'm at a really out of time now okay
thank you oh and let's see I do have one
you can contact me at 40th parallel
Python and also check out Python after
dark a Python bridge and also etc okay
thank you